yacht le monde sait ce cru voilà c'était
un moment un peu secte et aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur l'extension d'une classe
qui est sorti hier qu donc je propose
tout de suite de jouer à adibou déjà on
se réveille lâche moi parce que je suis
un petit bébé de 1 an et demi quoi papa
ah oui non à un bébé des bras comme ça
ces carreaux chelou ouvrait ses yeux
vous n'avez pas vous réveiller mais vous
devez ouvrir les yeux et si j'ai pas
envie que se passe t'il quelqu'un vous a
frappé c'est un troll sous bagel ce wake
watts
deux heures plus tôt vous ne me
connaissez pas il faut que je fasse vite
il sommeille peut-être j'ai fait une
mission de deux semaines en tant que
consultant logiciel sur un site demeure
coach se passe des choses terribles là
bas je n'y comprends rien je
actuellement les croyait bien trouvé de
mieux pour j'arrive à vous lire la suite
je suis désolé cordialement les gens
souffraient murkoff s'en met plein les
poches
il faut des voiles hissées au public qui
est là non c'est pas moi ok alors ils
ont déjà essayé de vous joindre trois
fois il ya urgence ce moteur je suis est
menacé ça pouvait me répondez vous pas
votre bipper je vais leur dire non à
leur dit pas est ce que contre une
bonbonne de gaz vous ne leur dit pas
pourquoi tu fais mon regard pourquoi tu
fais moria remarque enfin mérité vous
aux espaces quoi je sais ce que vous
faites tout ce que vous avez à l'aide et
des mois et des mois ils vont violer des
me violer me violer toulouse handball
estate quoi tu pourras est une petite
musique classique mignonne que ce serait
pareil ouais on le laissait pas faire ça
empêcher les vous je sais que vous et
arrêtez ça tirait à mon gars c'est ça
c'est la nouvelle attraction de citer
lands à celle de la faction vous avez
fini vous pouvez partir devait sortir
cette pièce monsieur mais qu'est-ce que
je fais là mon gars tu vois je fais des
claquettes cessa fut mon regard grosse
merde où est mon bureau c'est ici oh
[ __ ] et ses bouffées l'étagère est
tombé dans le coma fin du jeu cause
quelques uns sont trop bavard par ici ah
non j'espère pas vous soumettrez
volontairement confinement avez vous
entendu cela garde non vous n'avez rien
entendu
card va te faire vous faire des
expériences plutôt bizarre sur moi
whistleblower a donc non voilà sur la
fameuse chaise
o qui m'a libéré ok donc lui se lève
d'accord c'est comme ça qu'on parle
juste boîte s'est fait défoncer par
autour de fantômes à garder je vois rien
lumière s'il vous plaît ah bah oui la
fameuse caméra
oh je vais vous ouvrez les yeux vous
ouvrez les yeux vous montrez vous faire
vibrer vous attendez là non je veux pas
je te donne des pilules si tu peux c'est
gratuit open bar je m'en vais boîte à
fond
oh oui non en fait je m'en fais à ces
petits c qu'est ce tu fais mon gars tu
vas tu as billet direct oui je trouve
une porte
oya pas barre dans les toilettes yukon
très étonné qu'ils s'y font assez déjà
déjà je ne vous fais un pas de me
regarder comme ça
ok faites ce que vous voulez regarder
mois d août en bas c'est bon on n'y a
plus d'esprit oui je suis copain avec
vous un foyer dans la trame ici présents
mettez un peu de rouge selon romain car
celui-ci avant que je ne change d'avis
est déjà tu me parles mieux direccte
directions je fais un gros zoom sur ton
et mon gars ah ah ah on se moque de toi
en plus au mas oh [ __ ] j'ai déjà
inscrits mais en plus au fil des
mutations position foetale en temps de
décrire une poésie puis daqui steve mtow
vers la porte aux wee aa alors à
attendait mais c'est possible cette
position je m'attendais à voir une main
et la robotique c'est son pied
c'est quoi ces ondes ça screamer hockey
au [ __ ] je l'entends dû se relever à
droite je savais entendu à à tubes
célèbres gratte et ça marche ça va mieux
bon gauche ou droite
j'ai pris la gauche je suis passé le
stand bonne idée de même laissé soeur
tennessee s'il vous plaît appelez sur le
bouton ouvrait la porte ont présenté ici
ensemble
oui mon copain tu vas mourir chaussures
dans deux secondes
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une pile un nom ça
c'est un stabilo je me fais suivre je me
fais suivre ou pas va-t'en va-t'en
va-t'en de là mon gars à la [ __ ] au
[ __ ] j'ai vu un bras nus steaks hachés
non non non non objection
oui oui à ces couacs estime arrive il y
en a quatre qui arrive aux [ __ ]
j'arrive maison mais mes côtés mais
bakar attendait aller ya un truc à faire
un monte n'aime pas les vaches bleues
s'étaient pas les vaches bleues bon
voilées ou bordel de cul
dois je suis sûr qu'il faut passer
au-dessus allez mon gars tu peux aller
rappelle toi les cours d'acrosport leur
quatrième allez allez bon j'avais
développé tous cas une solution ou
est-ce que votre jeu est nul à chier
il y à une planche au dessus de vous
cordialement 2 assas à coucher changes
une pile je le savais et ça c'est pas
comme ça qu'on doit informer tout corps
sur les pas juste les pieds fin qui fait
du bruit [ __ ] j'entends gémir depuis
20 minutes j'en ai marre à la fin c'est
toi faire des cd v max d'accord un
pot-au-feu aux mains pour la table 4
qu'est-ce qui fait le nouveau plat près
de trois minutes au micro-ondes la tête
de votre père y avait une pile je les ai
vus à non bah non c'était une poêle mon
pile-poil voilà si on peut passer je
pense ne nous regardez pas je laime
nouveau tu lèves tu loupes sentais qu'à
tuer enlever son coeur et tu manges
[ __ ] il a mangé comme un flamby quoi
ça pue le bal urines
attends je changeais de piles à des mots
il fait tout noir attend mais qui met du
parquet dans les toilettes
il ya un gros problème détachez les
menottes ok faut aller chercher la clé
qui va être là et avoir un bon gros
spectre va devoir courir ça se passe mal
je dois nourrir ouah ouah ouah mais
battu saint vincent bogard
tout de suite d'un matelas qu'ubs allait
bien on sèche à l'aller nous attend pas
nous attend pas nous atteint pas fait
perdre sa sieste
ah mais non mais je déteste ce genre de
trucs
il nous a vus oui oui oui oui on avait
bien pas pour le mettre ça à mon avis le
matelas s'intéresse pas aux appelait le
4k culotte
il est plat et plus largement garoche
absolument que j'adhère c'est qu'à saint
pierre de weck en position foetale pour
des cartons à l'humiliation faut que
j'attende qui passe on est d'accord ça
ce serait qu'on perd maintenant c'est à
ce moment là il fallait que j'y aille
regardez le mec tout nu avec ça si
copains j'ai passé mission
d'infiltration l'ap s'est pas tu ta fils
30e des mecs trop stylé en armure à
carragher dans la tute infiltrer les
tons et demi ça avec tout nu avec une
scie kouakou kouadio a tenté un truc
hein il va finir dès que je vais avancer
vous allez voir le moment de tension au
à l école par hasard vous attendent dans
le coin il va pas nous voir ils auraient
une brindille je serais déjà les mails à
606 quoi donc c'est pas trop me dis pas
qu'il est là une pile s'il vous plaît
une pile
mon dieu oh le maigre en tout cas ils
élèvent cas il est l'auto n'était plus
là la clé pas la poubelle non la gêner
dans des récits slips et caleçons ou
quoi mais aux lettres mais john hayes
need to tell you secrète 10 - veilleuse
et laisse moi te plaît cela est quoi la
clé des menottes
ok j'ai la clé jacques les menottes ou c
ou au plus tard
allez va rattraper les jambes je le sors
je le sens don de bsca terme mesure au
le berceau de la menotte
yes and now s'il ya quoi
calme-toi quelle moto elle apporte ta
rien fait aux mines on sait mais qu'est
que ça si la viande est mienne non non
mais moi je suis fait en viande je suis
vieux allaitent
y'a rien à manger tu restes ici et tu
cuit watts
or il faut que je casse allez on cuit
mon gars yes bon au moins on était cuit
au feu de bois le mec tout à l'heure
c'était micro ondes
oh là je l'aï dit que se trouvait à je
vous l'avais dit non mais je suis là on
était tout à l'heure à sauvegarde et
[ __ ] de bâtard
je savais je le sentais allez on joue à
cache-cache aux steaks hachés
je suis cachée non au temps au tour auto
autour du pot ale autour du pont a
laissé un petit marathon mais non mais
tu t'énerves pas assez bon
c'est quoi ces petites fesses la bad en
hausse et une plage c'est la glace fond
à l'espoir
ça suffit je suis perché n'ont sûrement
pas comme ça sous le bureau bin talal
homme à la cie aux petites fesses quoi
fois la droite manière c'est sur faut
aller à droite
allez on vit on vit on vit on vit on vit
le casier le quasi aller si le casier si
le casier non non mais le casier on a
dit ok vous dites est mauvais je
respecte pas les règles aussi bon
j'aimerais bien juste passé eu
non mais c'est une blague ou quoi
longages apparaît je suis en face de lui
vas-y tu vois tu vois qu'on en finisse
vas-y tu moi ça te fait plaisir au moins
est ce que ça te fait plaisir aux côtes
ont regardé le hobo ah oui là on est bon
on est bon là on est bon on tient un
truc c'est bon on estimerait d'affaires
pièces coupées le coupé le gaz ou plus
je peux pas je peux pas assez marqué
d'actifs je peux pas couper le gaz tame
baiser mais est-ce que chef de ménage de
ce truc quoi ça suffit je démissionne
j'en fais plus moi tout ça le gaz
l'homme à la sio petit cul étouffe un
jour j'en ai marre et voilà les gens
c'est déjà fait
cette première vidéo sur l'extension
deux classes sorti hier j'ai bien kiffé
ça m'a rappelé de mauvais souvenirs
ne vous en faites pas je ressentirai
bien évidemment mégots et ma blouse deux
femmes de ménage dans une deuxième vidéo
pour finir extension n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo si ça vous a plu on se trouve
maintenant dans une nouvelle vidéo chat
ou le monde people
j'avais déjà fait celle-là est celle là
oui aussi si on a un truc que j'ai pas
fais peut-être oui la souris
et
m